President Vladimir Putin sharing a
meeting with his top security and
defense officials an image that projects
unity and stability within the Kremlin
at a time when Russia has come under
enormous pressure and scrutiny speaking
shortly after Vladimir Putin insisted
the country stands United behind his
government but he appeared visibly angry
dear friends today I address once again
all Russian citizens I thank you for
your endurance solidarity and patriotism
civil solidarity showed that any black
male any attempts to organize internal
unrest are doomed to fail
Wagner group and once among his closest
allies
frigojin now reportedly in Belarus
refuted claims that he had conducted an
act of treason in an audio message
posted on his telegram Channel he once
again denounced the Russian military
leadership
foreign foreign
had been monitoring closely the events
unfolding over the weekend
as the Wagner mercenaries seemed to be
advancing unabated towards Moscow
the White House said it had informed
Russia that neither the U.S nor NATO had
any role in the failed Mutiny but the
U.S has been cautious in his public
comments we also made clear to all our
allies and partners that the United
States was not involved and would not
get involved in these events and that we
view them as internal Russian matters
we delivered that same message to the
Russians themselves through appropriate
diplomatic channels I'll emphasize as
the president did just a little bit ago
that it's too early to speculate on the
impact these events might have or to
reach any definitive conclusions
but even with the Wagner Fighters gone
the war continues to grind on in Ukraine
tens of thousands of Russian troops
remain on the battlefield while Ukraine
attempts to claw back territory it lost
Al Jazeera